bullet cat podcast we got my guy snap
dog the very first snap dog freestyle
the first radio freestyle ever yeah
let's get it let's get to it man let's
get it
i'm gonna talk some little [ __ ]
[Music]
hey no i'm stepping about this [ __ ]
word on the street all my old hoes want
me back pistol on my lap real last step
when i'm black they say a [ __ ] acting
funnies with these racks i was down at
the bottom now i'm up and going back
it don't take [ __ ] to do a slide
say i'm on the go i'm on the rise when
[ __ ] see me out they look surprised i
came from the banos i was robbing got a
freak [ __ ] hit it like my side [ __ ]
imma keep it pee on hottie
do a slide mission on the low low
we were sliding loki in the photo
put it back aside for them legal fees a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ain't never did when i slide
for my [ __ ] [ __ ] they know i'm here
first yeah i'm lit through with that
draco imma show you how i work i just
seen [ __ ] tell that they have
paperwork i just seen broke [ __ ] act
rich on the first boy put that gun down
you ain't never dropped nobody you ain't
never slide you ain't never poor no
honey i be really trippin yeah that [ __ ]
really insane that's a dead man treated
his ass just like a zombie i didn't eat
the dawn out and gave a [ __ ] some deep
dick now seeing her friends and her
feelings on some teep [ __ ] texting me
crying and her feelings on that weak
[ __ ] know that [ __ ] mad cause she said
i wouldn't be [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] bronco boys [ __ ] already know we
sliding gliding hiding shutting our guns
out on jesus
as my mom and them [ __ ] first freestyle
on bullet cab [ __ ] [ __ ] let's get it oh
that's the end of the video
that [ __ ] was crazy bro appreciate it
guys hey i know you just watched a brand
new freestyle presented to you by our
good folks at lrg don't forget if you go
to lrg right now the website will be
right there broom l dash r dash g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get 30 percent off your order that's
l-r-g.com you'll see it right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week